what I did this morning was sign the
bill to finally eliminate their
self-governing status we've put the area
into State receivership I've appointed
people to to manage it we now have the
ability to apply Florida law to them
they used to be exempt from the building
code and all these other things we also
have the ability now so that they'll pay
their fair share of taxes which they
didn't have to do for the last 60 years
and of course they're going to honor all
the debts the Municipal debt that they
rung up 700 million dollars and so that
is um basically treating them like we
treat Sea World they're going to be just
another company
people I'm not even doing a proper intro
for today's show you know the guy I end
basically every one of my daily shows
with them the governor of the Free State
of Florida Ron DeSantis Governor how are
you I'm good how you doing I'm all right
I saw you at the freedom conference this
past weekend and I said to you that I'm
not going to bang you up too much in
this interview I have a feeling you'll
be okay through this one so look
everyone knows how I feel about Florida
things are cooking right are you just
are you just feeling great about how
things are going here because that's
really how everyone's feeling at the
moment
well there's energy here I mean I think
and you know you're part of it because
you know you were in a place that really
used to be the the place where people
would go for the American dream
California and to see people coming 3
000 miles to Florida and being really
happy and feeling the excitement and the
energy it's really a unique time in the
history of the state but but it didn't
happen by accident I mean it really was
a result uh of us making certain
decisions that yes we were going to be a
free state yes we were not going to end
up becoming a faucian dystopia yes we're
going to stand for the right things
across the board and people have really
responded as you know were the fastest
growing state in the country we've led
the nation a net in migration every year
since I've been governor and what's
happening in the California Illinois New
York they're having net out migration
they're hemorrhaging people and yes
that's happened in New York and Illinois
uh for for a decent amount of time but
California was never a place people left
uh they had never had net net migration
out migration until like four years ago
from the time it was a state and so I
think it's something that people are
very sensitive about the state
governments that they live in there's a
wide Chasm between quality of life in a
place like Florida where woke goes to
die and some of these other places where
they're really embracing woke ideology
to really devastating impacts on things
like Public Safety where people don't
feel safe in some of these cities
anymore because so much of it's governed
by ideology rather than the best
interests of the public so you just
bounced around some of those blue states
and cities to talk about law enforcement
and a couple other things we played a
bunch of clips of you were the local
officials there maybe even the Democrats
kind of like Hey Ron thank you for
coming here and can somebody fix this
thing I mean are they secretly on the DL
rooting for someone like you to show up
and and fix things because we just know
it's not happening in these blue cities
so it's interesting and in Chicago the
Chicago one was the most publicized
because it was with the Fraternal Order
police very powerful organization and it
had been publicized I guess like a week
in advance and so the left in Illinois
was really working a gin up protest
against me when I came so I'm pulling in
and this was like an American Legion
Hall so they had to cap it there was
capacity uh for who could get in and I'm
looking for these protesters and I'm
seeing all these people outside kind of
hooting and hollering and they all had
signs welcoming me there were some
protesters but there weren't very many
but the rest were really thankful for
that and so I think the issue is is you
know some of these politicians kowtowed
to the left the governor there some of
these people running for mayor but I
think you go underneath that and
particularly for individual voters
regardless if you're a Republican or
Democrat you know that what they're
doing is wrong when they just abolished
cash bail at the beginning of the year
New York did that and it failed why why
would you go down that road if you're
Illinois yet they're doing it so I think
people just want some sanity imposed I
think they like the fact that Florida we
really are common sense about a lot of
this stuff but we very much are proud of
being a place where police officers want
to work because they know that it's not
just me supporting them at the state
government that's important because if
you have a governor it's not supportive
it's bad for morale but you go to the
individual communities whether it's
where you are down in South Florida
whether it's the Panhandle people in the
communities genuinely appreciate the
people that wear the uniform and that
makes a difference for them yeah I'm
down in South Florida below Miami I
don't want to say exactly but I met my
local mayor here and he told me we have
not had a home break-in in 14 years 14
years it's just nuts so all right I know
we have we have limited time here so on
the on the Disney front and that whole
that whole Fiasco that seemingly has
just disappeared you kind of beat the
kingdom do you feel like you can now
kind of wash your hands of this thing
and Disney will behave differently and
and that there really will be some
concrete changes here
well actually what I did this morning
was sign the bill to finally eliminate
their self-governing status we've put
the area into State receivership I've
appointed people to to manage it uh we
now have the ability to apply Florida
law to them they used to be exempt from
the building code and all these other
things we also have the ability now so
that they'll pay their fair share of
taxes which they didn't have to do for
the last 60 years and of course they're
going to honor all the debts the
Municipal debt that they rung up 700
million dollars and so that is um
basically treating them like we treat
Sea World they're going to be just
another company and you know I wish
everybody well in Florida but here's the
thing they decided to take uh political
positions against our policy which they
have a right to do don't get me wrong
but they did that while enjoying this
special self-governing status that no
one else in Florida enjoyed they did it
while enjoying subsidies and exemptions
and all that stuff so it's basically
they're going after our policy and we're
subsidizing their activism so that was
untenable so I think we had no choice
but to act and so now you have a
situation where they had one of the
biggest sweetheart deals in modern
American history and that is now Up in
Smoke so since the title of the book is
the courage to be free I've heard you
obviously publicly and privately talk
about fighting with the media and I get
a sense that you really like it like you
kind of like when they go after you it
doesn't even matter which side it's
coming from is that something that you
kind of learned on the job or were you
oh did you always have that kind of
innate courage yourself
well I think in terms of just uh you
know the courage to stand for what's
right and and for freedom in this day
and age as you know so many of the elite
institutions in our society including
the media but also big Tech also the the
major corporations universities the
bureaucracy uh they are pursuing a more
woke left of center agenda and so if
you're somebody that's an impediment to
that if I'm standing here in Florida and
say no no not on my watch this is where
Wilkos to die well they're not going to
like that and they are going to come at
you uh and they're going to shoot at you
and you've got to be willing to take
that and you've got to be willing to
fight back but if you're somebody that
thinks in this day and age standing for
the right things is going to be cost
free then you're in the law then you're
in the wrong line of work and so I I
it's not that you enjoy it but I view it
as positive feedback when I have
Governors all these Democrat Governors
just attacking me you know unilaterally
I have the New York New York media
obsessed with tacking me well they
wouldn't be doing that Dave if I wasn't
effective and if I wasn't making a
difference and so that tells me we're on
the right track and we've got to keep
going but it's not just a guy like me
who's governing a big state yeah I'm a
Target you know you have parents that
have gone to school board meetings to
raise concerns about some of the things
that are going on in the schools and
they get smeared by media hell Merrick
Garland wanted to mobilize the FBI to go
after some of the parents and so it's
not just whatever level you're at uh
just know that there will be some
pushback but ultimately if we want to
maintain Florida as a free state and if
we want to have a Revival Across America
where our true principles are honored
that makes us unique you're going to
have to fight these fights and you are
going to have to pay a certain price in
terms of what people say about you and
the opposition that you generate right
and we show the pictures pretty much
every day but the same media guys who
are going after you they end up
vacationing in in Miami Beach on the
Panhandle and everywhere else all right
let me ask you I will ask you actually
one tough one so this isn't all softball
stuff uh in terms of the amount of
people that are coming here now and last
I heard it was about 1200 people a day
the one thing that seems to be tough in
Florida right now is that housing prices
are because of the amount of people
coming in housing prices are rising they
seem to be rising across the country
even in places people are fleeing but
what can be done on that front so that
the you know the OG Floridians don't
feel like they're getting pushed out and
all the new people feel like they can
get a fair price
yeah no it's a great question I mean you
know on the one hand uh we're a victim
of our own success on that because the
demand is high to live particularly
where you're at
um well one thing we are going to do
we're going to accelerate a lot of our
infrastructure projects so I have a
bunch of projects in the hopper that are
important for alleviate traffic all this
stuff all across the state uh we're
putting an extra seven billion dollars
in so I can get those done 13 years
ahead of schedule because some of these
are on a 20-year plan we don't have 20
years too many people are coming so
having that infrastructure in place I
think is important that can also make it
easier uh to continue to build new
housing we do have it going up all over
the all over the state like never before
but it still hasn't kept pace with
demand so the legislature is going to do
a bill uh to to try to address uh some
of the needs in certain areas and it's
not just about you know the people that
can afford uh you know the big houses in
the suburbs are nice we have a lot of
people who are very working class
working jobs May maybe they're a
waitress or something and it's hard to
find an apartment in certain parts of
the state so we want to see more of that
type of housing be able to be built so
there's going to be a big package that's
done and I think it'll I think it'll
help but at the end of the day we've
always been a state that's grown we are
building but man the growth is
outstripping how fast these guys can
build the homes now of course the
inflation has been a huge problem
because construction costs have gone
through the roof so what used to be a
home you know in some excerpt for 250
000 now that's costs more so that they
got to charge over 300 000 put aside the
demand and of course the demand drives
it even higher how much do you feel like
you're fighting the the federal
government on a daily basis I mean
obviously you know they cut FEMA kind of
early after Hurricane Ian the general
stuff with inflation as you just
referenced the die stuff that we're
doing things here in Florida that
they're pushing federally I mean do you
really feel like you're just constantly
at odds with them and does it even
matter I guess
yeah I mean look I think that we we are
protecting Floridians with all that
we've got uh against the excesses of the
Biden Administration I mean for example
they did the the mnra vax Mandate for
the hospitals and that was done under
CMS I had all these nurses they didn't
want to take it a lot of them had
already had covid many of them had
concerns and so I didn't think they
should lose their job over that but they
were going to impose this mandate
however they required the state of
Florida's Hospital agency to survey the
hospitals to ensure that the vaccines
were being done we rejected that we
decided that we are not going to help
this and so they didn't have the ability
to get the information they find us
which is fine find me I don't care we
save tens of thousands of jobs across
the State of Florida so anytime we can
step in and protect people against this
we do and we'll continue to do but
here's here just shows you what's going
on the administration you know that the
FDA forced their through emergency
approval for mnra vacs for six-month-old
babies they didn't have data they didn't
show was a benefit but they rammed it
through meanwhile I've had an
application under 2003 law that I did
during Trump's Administration it's been
sitting with Biden for over two years at
the FDA where I can my state agencies
can purchase drugs from Canada the same
drugs that we already buy here they're
just cheaper there's a provision of laws
we do it FDA says well we can't just we
were not sure it's safe so they'll stick
six-month-old babies with an mnra shot
on an emergency basis but they won't let
me buy these drugs no of course what
they're doing is they're basically
running interference for big Pharma and
that's typical of what Biden's been
doing so it's frustrating but I think
that we've done it oh by the way and and
maybe you can break this when it happens
we have a case in front of uh the
Northern District of Florida and the
Panhandle on Biden's Catch and Release
immigration amnesty policies we're going
to win that case it's it's been
submitted to the court we're just
waiting for the judge to rule we think
it's going to be probably sometime
um in March and I think it's going to
say his his uh catch and release is
unconstitutional that's going to have
them if that's probably Nationwide
they're going to have to reevaluate
their entire open border policies so
we're fighting back on a daily basis
well Governor you have blueprinted this
thing quite well which is why me and my
family moved here and I'm proud to be in
the fight with you and now I got one
more for you I know you're on a massive
Blitz and you got to get to number one
New York Times although the ultimate
credit would be if they don't put you on
at all because then you can really stick
it to them of course but is there any
other sort of announcement you might
want to make or anything else you might
want to talk about as long as we're just
chatting here you know anything else you
want to say about anything or we could
just end this now you tell me wouldn't
you like to know I mean that'd be that'd
be a good one for you but uh now listen
I appreciate uh you know your story and
and I'm really appreciative that you
really like the State of Florida because
I have similar stories and it and it
makes us feel like we're doing the right
thing so if people go to
desantisbook.com they can see some of
the uh the policies that kind of led to
that but uh when people stop beyond the
street and thank you uh for for having
for creating a great environment you
know that's why you get into this
business that's why you deal with all
the BS that you got to deal with because
ultimately you know you're helping make
people's lives better and we've been
able to do that here gov I'll just tell
you one last thing so when I moved here
and I'm walking my dog and everybody's
coming up oh you're the new guys living
over there and they say where are you
from and I'd go Cali Los Angeles and
they start freaking out so I realize
what I should do is I have to keep a
picture of me and you together on my
phone so when they say it I go no no no
I know this guy and then everybody's
like we're good Governor the book's
going to crush it uh I appreciate you
you helped change my life by getting me
here and my whole team and and two
companies now with Rumble and locals so
uh thank you and and hope to see you in
the first lady soon okay take care
thanks if you're looking for more honest
and thoughtful conversations about
politics instead of mindless dribble
check out our politics playlist and if
you want to watch full interviews on a
variety of topics watch our full episode
playlist all right over here and to get
notified of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
Bell